I
well however the immediately Universal
individuality is perverted in the source
of perversion this universal ordinance
since it is the law of all hearts that
is of what is perverted is no less
itself essentially perverted as the
ravings of the deranged consciousness
declared on the one hand this ordinance
proves itself to be a law of all hearts
by the resistance which the law of one
individual art encounters from other
individuals the established laws are
defended against the law of an
individual because they are not an
unconscious empty into sad necessity but
a spiritual universality and substance
in which those in whom this spiritual
substance has its actuality live as
individuals and our conscious of
themselves so that even when they
complain about this ordinance as if it
went against their own inner law and
maintained against at the opinions of
the heart they cling to it with their
hearts as being their essential being
and if this ordinance is taken from them
or they place themselves outside if they
lose everything since it is precisely in
this that the reality and power of
Public Order consists the latter thus
appears as a self identical essence
alive and everyone and individuality
appears as its form but this ordinance
is equally a perversion
we arrive now at the last three
paragraphs of this this section the law
of the heart and the frenzy of
self-conceit in which the problematic
situation is now going to be brought to
the fore and you notice that what we've
got here is what we might call a rather
pessimistic point of view where on the
one side we have the universal ordering
what hegel is going to call Public Order
and also the established laws and on the
other side we have the individual
motivated by the law of the heart you
notice that we have perverted here and
we have perverted and perverting there
both sides are equally screwed up or at
least screwed up enough perhaps this
side is a bit more screwed up because it
isn't engaged and actively perverting
right but what have we arrived yet well
earlier just a few you know paragraphs
leading up to this we saw the
development of a contradiction that
could not be reconciled within
consciousness and the self-consciousness
attempted to project it out onto the
world on to the society and say I'm pure
and that fell apart and now that's been
realized and now it's sort of shifts to
the other side everything is is screwed
up what can we draw from that hagel
starts out by saying the immediately
universal individuality that's the human
person who is motivated by the law of
the heart attempting to enacted
attempting to make it happen you might
say they realize that this is perverted
that is it is turned away it's not
perverted in the sense of sexual
perversion necessarily probably not in
most cases right unless we're talking
about the domain of sexuality or ways in
which sexuality could intrude into say
the economic domain or other things
along these lines but it realizes that
there's something fundamentally wrong
with it earlier it saw this in turn
of coming to terms with its own semi
insanity it's the contradictions lying
within it so he says it's perverted and
it's also a source of perversion why
because it realized that what was
happening in the the universal ordinance
was in part because it was universal it
was stemming from the universalization
that occurs in any action that we engage
in so society being screwed up i'm not
totally responsible for that but in a
certain way by wanting to make things
happen and and impose an order at all i
end up not identifying with but but
becoming partly responsible partly
culpable partly entangled in that and he
says this universal ordinance since it's
the law of all hearts that is of what is
perverted is no less itself essentially
perverted that is as the ravings of
deranged consciousness declared and that
was we have here bold action and we have
ravings right and acting in the world
and a condemnation of the world a
condemnation of the world is as screwed
up one that also of course turns in upon
itself as well now Hagel goes on and he
says on the one hand this ordinance over
here proves itself to be a law of all
hearts by the resistance which the law
of one individual heart encounters from
other individuals you remember several
paragraphs ago when this person
attempted to make the law of their heart
into the universal ordinance they ran
into other people who are like hey wait
a second who made you king who made you
though the ruler who left it up to you
to decide what a heart actually desires
and we saw that there could be a clash
between individual hearts
he goes on and he says the established
laws are defended against the law of an
individual somebody trying to change it
why because they are not an unconscious
empty and dead necessity this is what we
saw at last paragraph but a spiritual
universality and substance now this is
very important now we're getting back to
ethical substance in a very explicit way
what we were originally looking at early
on in the introductory materials to this
this entire subsection hagel continues
and he says it's a spiritual University
oversee allottee and substance in which
those in whom this spiritual substance
has its actuality live as individuals
and our conscious of themselves this is
something worth mulling over so in the
past what we've been treating this as is
we've got the universal ordering and
perhaps there's some individuals up on
top running the show the you know
fanatical priests the gluttonous tyrants
their minions who are looking to
dominate somebody and accept domination
is that as the the coin that they have
to pay and then we have suffering
humanity beneath but that's not all
that's going on even in societies that
are genuinely screwed up in which there
are terrible abuses taking place there's
still this process of the spiritual
substance constituting the very
possibility of being of these
individuals I mean you are an individual
insofar as you're not just an individual
and you exist as a part of something not
merely a part not just a cog in the
machine but but you belong you know it's
like Aristotle said in the politics an
isolated person is like one piece alone
on a
on a checkerboard it's not exactly
checkers back in ancient Greece but you
get the point there's no game there's no
meaning to the piece totally isolated
from itself and that means that not only
are these individuals encompassed within
that so is this one so is the one who
wanted to change things in accordance
with the law of the heart the principles
that are flowing from the sentimentality
that they are motivated by in an
immediate way so he goes on and he says
these these individuals live as
individuals in our conscious of
themselves now notice the next thing
that he says here this is really
brilliant even when they complain about
this ordinance as if it went against
their own inner law and maintained
against it the opinions of the heart
they cling to it with their hearts as
being their essential being and if this
ordinance is taken from them or they
place themselves outside of it they lose
everything people do [ __ ] and gripe and
sometimes legitimately so against the
established order against the way we do
things against society and they don't
realize in doing so quite often that
they get to do that precisely because
society does exist and provides a matrix
within which that is a possibility for
them if they truly got what it was that
they say that they want they might find
themselves entirely outside of it this
is what happens when you you know start
thinking about utopian schemes and what
it would be like if they were in fact
enacted how it would radically transform
or destroy society and alter the nature
of the human being or Hagel might say
repress the nature of the human be a
another dynamic that comes up with this
is when this person over here very
earnest wanting to change things you
know sees these others complaining and
saying hey we don't like the order
that's there maybe they're not quite as
serious about change as this person over
here is and so they enact it then these
people are like wait a second we didn't
want you to get rid of the ruling party
we didn't want you to change all the
rules we just had a few complaints what
you're putting in place is even worse
and that this person over here is you
know quite understandably upset because
of that so he goes on and he says since
it's precisely in this what's this this
relationship here it's precisely in this
that the reality and power of Public
Order consists the latter thus appears
as the self identical essence alive and
everyone and individuality appears as
its form this not the law of the heart
is what is more real more driving more
essential and its present in all of
these hearts now as the individuality
and then he says but this ordinance is
equally a perversion this does not get
us through the actual problem but now we
see that things that sort of swung over
to this side
the fact that it is a law of all hearts
that all individuals are immediately
this Universal means that the ordinance
is a reality which is only that of the
individuality that is for itself whereas
only the reality of the heart the
consciousness which sets up the law of
its heart therefore meets with
resistance from others because it
contradicts the equally individual laws
of their hearts and these others in
their resistance are doing nothing else
but setting up and claiming validity for
their own law the universal that we have
here is that only a universal resistance
and struggle at all against one another
in which each claims validity for his
own individuality but at the same time
does not succeed in his efforts because
each meets with the same resistance from
the others and is nullified by their
reciprocal resistance what seems to be
public order that is this Universal
state of war in which each rests what he
can for himself execute justice on the
individuality of others and establishes
his own which is equally nullified
through the action of the others it is
the way of the world the show of an
unchanging course that is only meant to
be a universality and whose content is
rather the essence lyst play of
establishing and nullifying
individuality
paragraph 379 now ushers in a sort of
unmasking or if you like in more
technical terms a dialectical analysis
of society that shows that it's really a
concealed state of war at least at this
point not every society in every way but
but at least looked at at this stage in
terms of the law of the heart you know
like a lot of things crisscrossing on
the board and that's this resistance and
conflict of laws of the heart coming
into conflict with each other so Hagel
starts out by talking about the law of
all hearts this Universal that we saw as
you know the last paragraph as being
this you know universal substance a
spiritual substance we could call it
ethical substance if we like and that's
going to be shown as something other
than then what we take it to be he says
the fact that it is the law of all
hearts that all individual all
individuals are immediately this
Universal notice that key term they're
all individuals are immediately this
Universal they are not mediated Lee
through discipline through connection
with each other but they're all striving
to be that Universal to decide what
counts is the universal in an immediate
way that is by relying on their own
sentimentality their own passions their
own emotions their own desires and then
thinking that those somehow constitute
you know what is true he goes on and he
says this means that the ordinance is a
reality which is only that of the
individuality that is for itself there
is only the reality of the heart so what
does this mean forest this means that we
don't really have a law of all hearts or
a universal in play even though
everybody is striving for that and
fighting with each other in order to
establish it or two
control over it so he goes on he says
the consciousness which sets up the law
of its heart right so we start with this
one this individual sets up the law of
his heart as the universal runs into
resistance from others why they have a
law of their heart he says it
contradicts the equally individual laws
of their hearts so everybody now has an
idea about how things ought to work who
ought to be in charge what you no mores
ought to be respected which ones we can
dispense with how we should interpret
them who should be ranked in what order
what counts is fairness we go on and on
and that and that and they all have
feelings about it right they all feel
quite strongly about it why do they feel
strongly about it they want things to go
the way that seems fit to them and it
may not be you know just brute egotism
right we don't need to read a Hobbesian
state of war of all against all here but
what we do need to recognize is that
these people are in a competition with
each other it's no longer the struggle
to the death of you know the beginning
of self-consciousness no it's mediated
here in society in who controls the
language who controls the discourse who
controls the mores who controls the laws
and he goes on ax me says there's a
contradiction with the equally
individual laws of their hearts these
others in their resistance are doing
nothing other than what this person is
doing they are setting up their own
heart crossing this either that's how
I'm depicting it in two dimensions
they're crossing this one and going in a
different way and they're saying no no
not your heart my heart not your way of
looking at things my way and then this
person does that in turn and we have all
these people over here doing the same
thing we could like fill up the
chalkboard with all the permutations of
crisscrossing that could take place
right this is only with six people right
now we imagine we've got a whole society
with a thousand people all clamoring to
have their own point
you heard so he goes on and he says the
universal that we have here then is only
a universal resistance and struggle of
all against one another so what's
happening is we no longer have a
universal that is constituting everybody
and we can rely on this Universal is a
locus for agonistic contestation for
debate for rhetoric for making deals and
alliances all these sorts of things that
go along with situations of conflict
like that wheeling and dealing you might
say so what what can we say after that
then so the universal we have is only a
universal resistance each person claims
validity for his own individuality but
at the same time does not succeed in his
efforts nobody can get what they want in
this case because nobody is actually
willing to cooperate with the other
person they all want to be heard they
all want to have their point of view
acknowledged by the other person
remember self consciousness is
interested in recognition from the other
but nobody's actually getting it here at
this point so that why and part cuz
they're not giving it to anybody else
right they're all competing with each
other so he says what we have here is
each meets with the same resistance and
is nullified by the reciprocal
resistance so what seems to be public
order then what seems to be a workable
society is this Universal state of war
in which he says each rests what he can
for himself execute justice on the
individuality of others and establishes
his own and that is equally nullified
through the action of the others Hagel
calls this the way of the world and this
is that proverbial that's just the way
things are when we
this often out of a weariness or a
despair when we see that the world
doesn't work the way that it should that
the universal order isn't one that's
actually fair or even transparent to us
and and we're like yeah okay that's just
the way it goes right we don't usually
say that when things are going great we
don't say oh that's the way of the world
the world is just you know this hunky
dory place where everybody gets what
they want no we say that when things
have turned into this morass of
competing interests and whoever wins may
not be the person who deserves to win so
this is what we're going to be talking
about quite a bit in the next section
the way of the world what is the way of
the world the show of an unchanging
course that is only meant to be a
universality what do we mean by that
there's an ideology we might say of
universality and by universality we
could talk about equality fairness we
could talk about proportionality
anything that's principled when we look
at the way societies actually work and
who gets things who gets their point of
view acknowledged it never turns out to
be totally in accordance with principle
does it even when we're trying to be
descriptive and talk about ideal types
all you know mocks behavior or somebody
like that it doesn't conform to that
quite so well either so he says it's
only meant to be a universality and
whose content is rather the essence list
play of establishing and nullifying
individuality now that's a very abstract
way to talk at this point what does
Hagel mean it means that these people
are competing with each other over what
we might call the space of public
discourse legislation playing out
interests they are each attempting to
impose the way that it looks like it
ought to be for them the way that things
seem they would work best what conforms
to their heart
and they're meeting with this resistance
from others that requires them to in
some ways fight against those others so
what is this going to turn into well
let's look at the next and last
paragraph
if we contrast the two sides of the
universal ordinance we see that this
latter universality has for its content
the Restless individuality which regards
mere opinion or individuality is law
what is real is unreal and what is
unreal is real but it is at the same
time the side of the reality of the
ordinance for two it belongs
individuality is being for self the
other side is the universal in the form
of a tranquil essence but is for that
very reason only something inner which
though not absolutely non-existence
still has no reality and can itself
become a reality only by getting rid of
the individuality which has irrigated
reality to itself the shape of
consciousness which in the law is aware
of itself which knows itself and what is
intrinsically true and good not as an
individuality but only as it becomes an
essential being and which knows
individuality to be perverted at the
source of perversion and therefore knows
it must sacrifice the individuality of
consciousness this shape of
consciousness is virtue
with paragraph 380 we now arrive at the
very end of this section and we're ready
to make a transition into the next
section which is virtue and something
else will be referenced in the last
paragraph the way of the world how do we
get there how do we wind up in a new
shape a new result of consciousness well
Hagel begins this paragraph by talking
about the universal ordinance which we
saw in the past paragraph was turning
into a grounds of contestation but now
he's going to say that it splits itself
off into these two sides what we can
recognize in here is in some respects a
mirroring or at least an echo of the
unhappy consciousness right restless
individuality tranquil essence sounds
very very similar doesn't it there's
even sacrifice going on so you know we
should we should think back to that and
see that as brought in here he's also
bringing up out hey bong you know subway
shin or transcendence you know however
you want to translate it is being
referenced here as well so he says if we
contrast these two sides we see that the
latter universality has for its content
the Restless individuality which regards
mere opinion or individuality as law
what is real is unreal and what is
unreal as real so it's conflicted with
in its very being it's regarding what is
real as unreal and vice versa this goes
back to the you know state of this in
frenzy of self-conceit right but now
notice what else he's saying here it
regards opinion mining and now higgles
played a lot with this word mining it
does mean opinion but it also means you
know appropriation to oneself it's my
opinion right so opinion and into the
Jew
ions aldehyde specific specificity being
on its own right as law and we saw that
there were some you know inherent
contradictions in trying to elevate
universality into a law because it goes
against this whole you know principle of
ordering individuality xin relation to
each other what do we have on the other
side so henkle talks here about the side
of the reality of the ordinance right
that's this side the the being for self
this is what is real this is what is
ideal and that doesn't mean that it's
just some sort of pipe dream he says
that it's it's not yet real but it is to
be realized Hagel doesn't look at ideals
as things that you know we just have out
there and never never land and we can
just sort of approximate to them but
never actually reach them no ideals
become real by realizing them and
there's usually some way in which that
happens so he talks here about the
tranquil essence and he says this is the
universal in the form notice this was
content this is form of a universal of a
tranquil essence and then he says it is
for that very reason only something
inner it needs to be externalized it
needs to be made outer it needs to be
made real it is not yet real so he he
says it still has no reality and can
itself become a reality how it becomes a
reality here Miller has a you know
unhappy translations he says getting rid
of the the individuality which is
irrigated reality to itself what Hagel
is actually saying is it becomes a
reality by subway shin or sub lading of
hey bong of the individuality which has
irrigated reality to itself and how does
it do so it doesn't do so by some action
its own side it does so precisely by
this Restless individuality doing
something which is a sacrifice so he
goes on and he says this shape of
consciousness which in the law is aware
of itself which knows itself in what is
intrinsically true and good which is
this right this Restless individuality
has realized itself as perversion and as
having also perverted the universal
ordinance so the only way in which it
can get in touch with what is true and
what is good which is what what it
thought it was in touch with with the
law of the heart is by sacrificing its
own individuality to and to become this
tranquil essence so he says it knows
itself in what is intrinsically true and
good not as an individuality but only as
it becomes an essential being and it
knows individuality to be perverted and
the source of perversion therefore it
knows it must sacrifice the
individuality of consciousness Hagel
says this shape of consciousness is
virtue togan something aiming at a
universal that is not simply you know
destroying the individual right but
subletting it raising it to a higher
level where it's no longer just an
individual struggling against a whole
bunch of other individuals but
expressing living out something
something different and notice this can
only occur in this stage of the
dialectic when the Restless
individuality comes to recognize itself
as perverted and as a source of
perversion when it tries to actually you
know externalize the law of the heart
into the organism of society and finds
it there there are there are all sorts
of screwed up consequences including
turning the other laws of the heart
again
that if it doesn't do that it's not yet
ready to have this raising up to a
higher level occur and to to have virtue
that's why the virtue and this is a
little bit of digression that I'm going
to close on that's why virtue so often
as Pollyanna sh what people call virtue
signaling right not real virtue if it's
real virtue there is some sort of
sacrifice um subordination of the
individuality to something higher than
him or herself which then incorporates
them and turns them into something more
than just their individuality how is
that going to play itself out well that
is what we have to see in the section
yet to come this is how the law of the
heart founders shipwrecks if he likes in
the course of the dialectic
you